nous passons maintenant directement au
festival de cannes après la soirée
d'ouverture la compétition a vraiment
commencé aujourd'hui à ce festival
alors tout de suite je vous propose les
comptes rendus de nos envoyés spéciaux
bonsoir avant de vous parler de la
sélection officielle aujourd'hui je
voudrais revenir sur la soirée d'hier
vous proposez une seule image hier soir
19h30 regarder
une image symbolique diront certains en
tout cas pour moi très émouvante
sélection officielle donc aujourd'hui
pour papillon un film argentin est tenue
de soirée de bertrand blier un film que
nous vous avons présenté déjà la semaine
dernière je n'y reviendrai pas pour
papillon c'est un film que j'appellerais
d'atmosphère il ya un ambiance terry
d'avoir les premières images sont bleuté
froide comme la merde argentine
nous sommes en 1945 et un groupe de
juifs un groupe de communistes font la
chasse aux nazis qui se sont réfugiés en
argentine c'est un film émouvant qui me
fait penser un petit peu d'ailleurs à
l'histoire officielle que nous avions vu
l'année dernière à cannes
maintenant on commence à voir la vérité
de ce que nous à nous a connu pendant
trente cinquante ans je dirais dès
qu'ils ont commencé les gouvernements
militaires légitimes aux classes ils
érigent fabrication l'argentine comme ça
vole internacional mais aussi une
histoire et beaucoup l'histoire parce
que d acceptation des 6000 mans parce
que la cep d'elles-mêmes comme les idées
là de la burqa la honda
la chaîne a recherché des des souris de
son dernier la religion et l'état vient
religion et sur l'esprit
au quartier général des américains de
carleton tout est en place
le décor est planté pour ce 39e festival
affiche des panneaux annoncent les six
films en compétition seulement voilà
etes-vous américain
f
non
et cetera et cetera pour tout dire
l'américain s'est fait rare on cherche
en vain les stars et faute de
combattants les trois grandes chaînes de
télévision américaines rentrent chez
elles
ici des choses beaucoup plus grand ils
ont été annulés les causes exactes n'ont
dans l'ensemble nous n'avons pas pour
ceux qui ont décidé de venir au festival
la position est claire c'est un problème
quelque chose où que vous soyez on ne
peut pas se laisser intimider par les
accus pénétrer dans la salle du palais
des festivals j'ai dû les sinon sa
quarantaine on a fouillé j'ai tué ses
filles lisa sion mon travail je n'ai pu
sauver que ma petite lampe qui me permet
de prendre des notes
l'anssi l'eau car ce ne sont pas des
armes terroristes je vais maintenant
vous parler d'un film allemand in fine
elle m'a sanders brahms la côte avec
sami frey et cristina yang saniflo
jeunes bleus présentent pas du sinaï
honda non plus elle est l'héroïne des
films d'andrzej wajda
c'est un film qui se passe à berlin dans
le secteur interdit il est architecte à
paris il m
les photographes en pologne à varsovie l
amour est impossible en tout cas une
très belle histoire c'est un thème
j'avais pour ce film des acteurs
vraiment merveilleux sami frey et
krystyna janda et qui représentait tous
les deux parce que je voulais avoir dans
le film le monde de l'ouest et le monde
laisse un rencontre entre saillans
rencontre entre un homme et une femme
je voulais tout concentrer dans une
heure et demie ce qui se passe entre un
homme et une femme qui se voit là pour
peut-être une dernière fois et qui ont
dû entre cette idée de peut-être pouvoir
faire une vie ensemble
ou un moment de vie ensemble et qui qui
comme beaucoup d'entre nous sont pas
capables de vraiment rester ensemble et
mais leur leur problème c'est encore
aussi qu' il ya entre eux un mur qui les
sépare plus que mon dans les relations
ici c'est juste le mur entre les l'est
et l'ouest qui qui est entre leurs
paroles entre leur manière de se porter
entre tout ce qu'ils font